et
stanislas bini qui nous rejoint ce matin
bonjour déléguée générale de la
république en marche merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité politique stanislas
guérini en détention pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale
représenté à fabrice minsart dont le
groupe ebra des journaux régionaux de
l'est de la france vont leur fabrice je
regarde parce que c'est bonjour
stanislas guérini emmanuel macron s'est
de nouveau entretenu hier avec vladimir
poutine entretien d'une heure quarante
cinq a dit l'elysée ça n'empêche pas
l'escaladé vladimir poutine a dit qu'il
restait déterminé qu'il tiendrait ses
objectifs par la négociation ou par la
guerre at il dit quelle est l'utilité de
ces échanges du coup est ce qu emmanuel
macron ne parle pas un peu dans le vide
faut chercher à tout prix je pense que
chacun peut le comprendre a gardé ce
canal là aujourd'hui mais dalmat compte
c'est le seul chef d'état qui continue à
parler à vladimir poutine à la demande
d'ailleurs de poutine ça doit être noté
il a vu cette expression le chef de
l'état devient il faut prendre tous les
risques pour essayer par la voie
diplomatique par le dialogue d'entraîner
des escales il faudra bien y venir un
moment donné mais le seul langage que
poutine comprends c'est le langage de la
force donc si nous avions été faibles
comme poutine l'attendait d'ailleurs
avec une union européenne qui se serait
disloqué avec l'otan qui serait resté
dans sa situation il ya deux ans c'est à
dire en état de mort cérébrale avec un
peuple ukrainien et avec des démocraties
d'air qui se serait couché je pense que
la situation serait différente
aujourd'hui donc il faut à tout prix
tenir puis à des objectifs de court
terme humanitaire tout simplement
permettre qui est des couloirs pour que
des civils qui sont en train de mourir
sous les bombes des enfants qui sont en
train de moins sous les bombes puisse
quitter les villes qui sont en ce moment
à siéger et détruites méthodiquement par
poutine des objectifs aussi sur le
nucléaire sur les centrales qui sont des
objectifs visiblement stratégique pour
poutine qui est dans une sorte de
stratégie de la terreur donc oui il faut
continuer ces discussions
je pense pas qu'ils attaquent pour les
faire exploser il faut dire les choses
de façon assez claire je pense que c'est
pour lui un objectif d'abord dans un
premier temps plus tôt pour avoir la
main sur l'interrupteur de l'ukraine si
je puis dire mais aussi il faut en être
conscient dans cette stratégie de
terreur vis-à-vis des ukrainiens et des
européens pour nous rappeler à chaque
instant que le nucléaire est là bien en
tête et je pense que jean yves le drian
d'ailleurs avait eu des mots assez juste
pour dire que l'otan c'était une
puissance nucléaire aussi il se sent par
les vrais dîmière poutine emmanuel
macron près de deux heures à nouveau
hier on aimerait tous d'ailleurs être
une petite souris pour savoir qu'est ce
qui se passe pendant ces deux heures
qu'est-ce que
jusqu'où on peut discuter avec la demie
à poutine jusqu'au bout moi je crois
vraiment que
arrêter le dialogue
s'est expliqué sur sip te parler avec
qui qui dit même sort et en bouclant
fallait pas se raconter d'histoires
l'admirent poutine aujourd'hui il a les
mêmes éléments de langage et il ne parle
même plus les ukrainiens mais des nazis
il est dans une sorte de rapport à la
grande histoire d être ça qui est assez
effrayante évidemment tout ça est vrai
mais je pense qu'il faut continuer à
parler à poutine particulièrement pour
la france parce que nous devons toujours
rappeler que nous ne sommes pas en
guerre contre la russie
dans ce moment là nous ne sommes pas
belligérants dans ce conflit et donc
nous avons la responsabilité de chercher
la voie de sortie est ce que dira cela
ça veut dire laisser tomber les
ukrainiens pas du tout et je pense que à
tous les niveaux au niveau des chefs
d'état au niveau de l'otan au niveau des
peuples aussi moi j'étais ce week-end
place de la république comme de nombreux
français partout en france comme de
nombreux européens plus nombreux encore
dans d'autres capitales européennes plus
on va vers l'est pour s'élever et dire
que nous ne laisserons pas tomber les
ukrainiens y compris en les aidant d'un
point de vue militaire les portières on
a dû faire entrer dans l'union
européenne exactement moi je me suis
exprimé sur le fait qu'il fallait
reconnaître leur statut de candidat je
pense que c'est très important ça veut
pas dire que là ils rentreront du jour
au lendemain non il faut pas abandonner
nos critères nos procédures il faut
qu'ils puissent rentrer mais dans ce
moment là où ils sont en train de mourir
sous les bombes et ils ont fait vous le
savez en 2014 une révolution ils ont été
réprimées durement certains ukrainiens
sont morts le drapeau européen entre les
mains à ce moment là je pense que il est
important de reconnaître leur statut
effectivement deux candidats on va avoir
des conséquences en france
jeudi un plan de résilience va être
présentée qu'est ce qui ne doit contenir
ce plan précisément bien pour moi il
doit accomplir deux volets si je puis
dire un à destination des secteurs
économiques d'une certaine façon le quad
qu'il en coûte doit pouvoir être
poursuivi mais de façon beaucoup plus
ciblées pour les secteurs qui ont des
liens directs avec la russie et puis le
deuxième volet c'est toutes les
conséquences de l'augmentation des prix
vous le savez les questions de
souveraineté énergétique et souveraineté
alimentaire elles sont exactement poser
dans le moment que nous sommes en train
de vivre je crois que le blé est à 400
euros la tonne il faut rappeler que
c'est un quart des céréales qui sont
consommés dans le monde les prix de
l'énergie évidemment et donc continuer à
protéger les français protéger les
entreprises aussi de l'augmentation des
cours de l'énergie
moi ce que je crois alors c'est pas
forcément comme ça qu'on doit le faire
mais ce que je crois c'est que sur
l'énergie le bouclier tarifaires que
nous avons votée et que nous avons
décidé de poursuivre toute l'année 2022
est un bon élément de protection avec
peut-être une attention spécifique
apportée sur certaines entreprises qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas concernés par ce
bouclier tarifaire n'augmente notamment
sur l'augmentation des prix du gaz
activité là aussi il faut dz je pense
qu'il faut le regarder de façon
spécifique évidemment vous savez moi
j'ai toujours considéré que le quoi
qu'il en coûte pendant la crise
sanitaire ça a été un investissement est
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui on peut en tirer
des bénéfices en repartant très fort en
ayant une croissance qui est la
meilleure des pays européens il faut
continuer à agir de cette façon là là
aussi sans céder à la panique je pense
que nous avons une économie qui est
robuste qui est moins dépendante que
d'autres aux échanges avec la russie qui
est moins dépendante que d'autres aux
augmentations du prix du gaz parce que
nous sommes moins évidemment dépendant
au gaz russe mais ça veut dire aussi
qu'il faut agir sur d'autres volets des
volets de plus long terme vous savez
hier un sommet jeudi et vendredi de tous
les chefs d'état européens
et c'est la responsabilité de la france
sous présidence française que ne posait
ses grandes questions là le marché de
l'énergie en europe est totalement
dysfonctionnelle entre le prix
aujourd'hui l'électricité est fixé sur
le prix du gaz bien ça c'est des règles
qu'il faut accepter aujourd'hui de
revoir ça fera partie des objectifs
français concrètement entre 80 et 100
euros pour le plein d'une voiture pour
en français une française aujourd'hui
c'est quelque chose de durable selon
vous
suis pas un spécialiste
donc c'est très
visible des êtres sur l'énergie sauf que
qu'est ce que vous faites pour aider les
français à faire leur plein d'essence
bon on a fait qu'il faut des êtres
supplément de cette indemnité de congés
à la fin de générique s qu'il en faut
une autre je dirais que il ya eu deux
volets d'abord l'indemnité
inflation pour essayer de toucher le
plus largement possible
la plupart des français et puis ensuite
il ya eu un deuxième geste sur le barème
kilométrique plus spécifiquement
destinés aux gros rouleurs parce que
c'est vrai que 100 euros ça couvre est
l'augmentation moyenne c'était pour un
rouleur moyen 81 euros par an donc en
apportant un chèque de 100 euros on
répondait à peu près aux besoins mais
pour quelqu'un qui est obligé de prendre
sa voiture pour aller travailler ça
répondait pas complètement donc le
barème kilométrique c'est une réponse il
faut continuer à regarder je pense pas
qu'il fait c'est qu'il faut d'une
certaine façon à une démagogie de dire
mettre des quelque chose qui bouge il
faut absolument un chèque mais en même
temps
j'entends parfois et des secours qui
sont parfois contradictoires en duo ou
cramer la caisse et puis en même temps
vous en faites pas assez donc je pense
qu'il faut regarder les choses calmement
aujourd'hui les mesures qui ont été
prises il me semble qu'elles répondent
aux augmentations tels que nous sommes
en train de les vivre mais si
effectivement elles sont très durable ou
saison tendance à augmenter encore les
faudra avec la même logique je dirais
d'investissements pour l'avenir
continuer à protéger les français pour
qu'ils puissent continuer à aller
travailler
il me semble qu'à ce stade d'un point de
vue dispositions législatives s'étaient
notamment cas sur l'énergie dans le
dernier budget nous avons pris les
dispositions qui nous permettent de
protéger les français donc à ce jour
elle pas besoin de faire siéger à
nouveau le parlement pour prendre des
décisions sur le gouvernement décidé
d'avoir des mesures budgétaires
ponctuelles il pourrait le faire sans je
crois avoir assez jeune on va parler de
la campagne la campagne qui ne sera pas
classique c'est ce qu'a répété hier soir
gabriel atta le porte parole du
gouvernement alors on nous annonce quand
même des meetings d'ailleurs
nous n'avons pas confirmé je pense que
chacun peut comprendre que le chef de
l'état il va profiter de tous les
interstices que l'agenda international
que son agenda présente la république
lui offre pour aller à la rencontre des
français donc
on n'a pas prévu de cette façon là on a
prévu que le candidat puisse se déplacer
ça cet après midi à poissy en fin de
journée pour échanger avec des français
moi je crois que c'est très important
il a eu la possibilité de leur écrire et
poser quelques grands thèmes une vision
pour le pays d'une certaine façon est un
projet pour le pays et maintenant faut
qu'ils aient un temps des changes un
temps de confrontation et je pense que
c'est particulièrement important de
pouvoir le faire et ça que ça veut dire
c'est qu'il y aura pas de meeting du
chef de l'état il ira dans des villes et
les
jours si si on vous entend bien jouer un
jour évidemment que il faudra beaucoup
d'agilité pour pouvoir profiter des
moments qui lui sont offertes pour
pouvoir échanger avec nos concitoyens je
dis pas qu aura pas de rassemblement
moment donné dans cette campagne mais
chacun peut comprendre que un format de
meetings 100% classique avec que des
partisans bah c'est forcément un moment
qui correspond pas ou une forme qui
correspond pas exactement au moment que
nous sommes en train de vivre moi je
crois que ce qui est très important
c'est surtout surtout de pouvoir
échanger d'aller directement parler aux
français de répondre aux questions
qu'ils se posent ça veut pas dire la non
plus que les journalistes pourront pas
interrogé le candidat ils ont évidemment
l'occasion de le faire mais pour
l'instant ce que je constate ça veut
dire qu'il sait c'est en
tout cas des émissions je crois que
l'ensemble des chaînes font des
propositions j'ai jamais vu le chef de
l'état ne pas accepter d'avoir des
moments de dialogue voir deux
confrontations de controverses pour
reprendre les mots même qu'il a à faire
campagne comme il l'aurait souhaité
c'est l'évidence mais vous savez j'étais
sur le terrain ce week-end et je pense
que les gens le comprennent tout
simplement que parfois on à ces couples
était babu de faire campagne dans le
contexte ça veut dire que c'est d'autant
plus utile de pouvoir se démultiplier
puisque lui-même ne sera pas aussi libre
qui voudraient de pouvoir aller mais
emmanuel macron il aime bien faire
campagne il aime bien convaincre et
généralement ça lui fait pas peur
d'avoir des moments d'échangés de
confrontation il a eu l'occasion de le
faire à maintes reprises dans ce
quinquennat mais je pense que les
français peuvent comprendre et je crois
qu'il le comprenne parfaitement que
dévier de ses responsabilités
aujourd'hui dans le contexte que nous
avons évoqués c'est ça qui serait pas
forcément très comprend ce ou pas de
campagne c'est le risque aussi d'une
participation importante moi je crois
que c'est un grand enjeu dans cette
campagne et aujourd'hui je le rappelle
souvent le premier parti de france ça
reste l'abstention et donc nous sommes
en train de parler souvent de sondages
d'études d'opinion etc qui repose sur
des sables mouvants réalité puisque il
ya encore quinze pour cent quinze points
de participation de certitude d'aller
voter aujourd'hui de moins qu'au même
moment en 2017 donc ça c'est un grand
enjeu et j'aurais juste d'un mot dire
que ce qui se joue en ce moment c'est
vraiment l'avenir de notation c'est
vraiment l'avenir notre continent et
j'entends parfois que les crises
effacerait la campagne mais c'est tout
le contraire qui doit se passer parce
que nous avons des grandes questions qui
sont posées sur la table de notre
capacité à maîtriser notre destin de la
souveraineté française est la
souveraineté européenne
on en parlait à l'instant sur l'énergie
sur l'alimentation mais il faudrait le
dire aussi sur notre capacité à
réindustrialiser le pays à fabriquer nos
produits propres nécessité vous parlez
avec marie noëlle lienemann juste avant
moi de la fabrication de médicaments
tout ça ce sont les questions qui sont
posées dans la campagne donc il faut que
ce débat puisse avoir lieu parce qu'il
ya des visions sociétés qui sont très
divergentes aujourd'hui les français ont
un choix extrêmement important à faire
en 2020 on voit que la vie
gouvernementale se poursuit dans la nuit
dans la soirée de samedi et dimanche sur
l'aspect en décours mini remaniement
ministériel avec le départ de madame et
linas du gouvernement suite à
un rapport une enquête pour harcèlement
le départ de gikongoro qui était plus ou
moins annoncée est ce que c'est le
remaniement qui était plus ou moins
annoncée avant cette avance est cette
prime ce premier tour présidentiel oui
il va y en avoir un autre je crois que
vous avez eu le bon terme remaniement
technique pour deux raisons à ces
différentes mais vous les avez vous les
avez rappelé je crois pas mais gpad
annonce à faire moi je suis pas porte
parole du gouvernement et j'en sais rien
pour vous dire la vérité
c'est encore
c'est formidable la façon dont les
choses se font parce que il ya beaucoup
de rumeurs de supputations beaucoup de
choses qui sont écrites sans que ça soit
de notre fait et ensuite il faut qu'on
commente a posteriori les supputations
qui en fait n'était pas avérée donc
c'est quand même quittera s'il ya eu ce
remaniement technique n'est pas
forcément pour en refaire un autre mais
je vais vous dire les choses très
franchement j'en sais rien c'est le
candidat lui-même qui est
sa campagne aujourd'hui les choses
fonctionnent aujourd'hui avec beaucoup
de personnalité qui sont impliqués dans
cette campagne et des personnalités
politiques qui sont impliqués dans cette
campagne je le disais le maître mot je
crois ça doit être l'agilité aussi pour
pouvoir organiser les choses et on l'a
bien vu en 2017 dans une campagne
présidentielle
pas une élection cantonale pas une
élection régionale le principal décideur
généralement c'est le candidat ou la
candidate lui-même où elle même et je
pense que c'est comme ça que les choses
doivent se faire un mot chef du parti
que vous êtes juste pour n'atteigne les
limaces qui a donc quitté le
gouvernement parce qu'elle est accusée
de harcèlement par son cabinet a dit
qu'elle va faire campagne pour le chef
de l'état est ce que pour vous à la sa
place dans l'équipe de campagne et sk
lors à l'investiture aux prochaines
législatives puisque elle dit aussi
qu'elle veut poursuivre son mandat de
député vous savez on a décidé de
respecter un calendrier qui est celui
d'abord la présence elle est ensuite des
relatives donc je vais pas dévier de ce
calendrier là parce que
ya des demandes des uns ou des autres
donc pour moi c'est absolument pas le
moment est là c'est une équipe de
campagne a eu dans l'équipe j'en suis
pas persuadé si elles souhaitent
s'engager et un engagement de longue
date et sincère je crois derrière le
président de la république évidemment
qu'elle puisse le faire mais je crois
que les choses se sont réglées cette
façon là avec une enquête interne et
puis visiblement une décision de sortie
du gouvernement c'est donc qu'il devait
y avoir matière pour qu'elle puisse
sortir de gouvernement moi je crois que
quand on plaide l'exemplarité il faut
qu'elle puisse s'appliquer donc une
décision d'autant que je crois logique
puisqu'il ya eu une enquête interne un
mot sur la campagne on parle beaucoup de
cyber attaques en ce moment avec là
guest que vous voulez redouté ces cyber
attaques sur la campagne du chef de
l'état bien sûr on a les avait déjà vécu
d'ailleurs en 2017 et donc il faut que
chacun puisse se préparer et paris-le
déstabilisation d'alors je pense que le
gouvernement et la force publique je
dirais à renforcer ses moyens et l'a
fait d'ailleurs en lien avec l'ensemble
des formations politiques
puis ensuite il faut le faire j'irai
dans une sorte de discipline interne et
nous nous ce que nous avons fait ce vont
former nos équipes nous le faisons déjà
depuis de nombreuses années dans les
partis politiques
nous l'avons fait aussi pour l'équipe de
campagne save est la meilleure
protection d'une certaine façon c'est
les bonnes réactions individuelles dans
ce type de cas je vous racontais peut
être une anecdote mais nous nous faisons
régulièrement des tests en interne pour
envoyer des faux mails des phishing
comme on dit pour vérifier que tout le
monde est prêt à bien réagir à pas
répondre est ce qu'on ne connaît pas et
c est temps en temps voyez un des
membres de l'équipe de campagne à qui on
dit ça ça a été vraiment une
cyberattaque carton serait fait avoir
donc il faut corriger le comportement je
pense que c'est beaucoup beaucoup
d'humain en réalité la protection contre
ces cyber attaques par rapport à 2010
c'est toulon sont les troupes dans
marche alors déjà j'ai noté que vous
parliez de partie 1 longtemps vous avez
refusé l acia pas de tabou moi je
préfère le moment au moment où haïti
pour une raison simple je trouve que
l'idée de mouvement elle donne cette
idée d'ouverture sur la société civile
qui est à mon avis absolument nécessaire
pour les formations politiques
aujourd'hui alors je pense que si on
comprend pas ça alors les parties vont
vraiment définitivement faut finir de
moorea que représentent les troupes là
aujourd'hui mais vous savez il ya
beaucoup d'adhésions en ce moment à la
république en marche combien là
aujourd'hui on est à quatre cent trente
mille adhérents ses 3000 adhérents par
mois en ce moment qui rejoignent les
rangs de la république en marche pour
pouvoir faire campagne moi je veux que
depuis le début je les portais de cette
façon là qu'on puisse le faire en
majorité présentielle serre que
l'ensemble des partis politiques qui
représentent la majorité présidentielle
qui s'est élargie dans ce cas qaîda
puisse le faire ensemble mais ce que je
vois c'est qu'il ya une une ferveur
militante qui est bel et bien là temps
en temps on va dire c'est un parti de
cliqueurs il ya personne tout ça est
virtuel moi j'ai jamais cru ça y compris
dans les moments difficiles y compris
quand on perdait des élections
municipales
départementales
ça a été dit oui je vais je pense qu'il
a regretté cette expression d'ailleurs
parce que il s'est rendu compte lui-même
que ce n'était pas vrai sur le terrain
qu'il ya toujours beaucoup de monde y
compris je pense que ça l'est dans la
vie politique faut faut être transparent
faisant la vérité oui on a vu deux
défaites électorales mais chacun réalisé
qu'ils participer à quelque chose qui
était peut-être plus grand que soi même
ça prend du temps d'implanter une
formation politique est aujourd'hui oui
il ya du monde qui a envie de faire
campagne et qui a envie de continuer à
s'engager vers le présent de la
république pour 50 plus un mot sur eric
zemmour il était hier en meeting à
toulon il a notamment attaqué le chef de
l'état emmanuel macron emmanuel macron
ferme les yeux sur vos craintes c'est ce
qu'il a dit assez
partisans hier ce qu'il a dit aux
français emmanuel là qu'on ferme les
yeux sur vos craintes il veut occulter
votre quotidien car votre quotidien des
mondes qu'il n'a rien fait qu'est ce que
vous répondez
j'ai sincèrement même pas tellement
envie moi de rentrer dans ce type
d'attaqué la distance je pense que vous
l'avez dit un peu de temps pour faire
campagne il ya des enjeux qui sont
absolument essentielles et donc nous
perdons pas de temps à faire campagne
contre nous nous avons en 2017 décidé de
faire campagne pour je vois les
candidats obsédé au fond de créer une
sorte d'affrontement avec le président
de la république parce que pense-t-il
c'est la seule façon de se positionner
comme un candidat ou une candidate de
deuxième tour moi je pense que tout ça
n'a pas d'intérêt passons du temps à
parler des français au contraire
emmanuel macron il disait que son
objectif c'était de faire baisser les
extrêmes aujourd'hui marine le pen plus
eric zemmour c'est 30% 40% si on ajoute
jean luc mélenchon est ce que là vous
avez échoué mais les extrêmes et il
était bel et bien là en 2017 il nous
n'avons pas choisi ils sont présents
alors on les a fait reculer dans les
différentes élections dans ce
quinquennat aux européennes notamment
puisque les extrêmes ont réussi on a
réussi à faire reculer les extrêmes à ce
moment là et je crois que la seule façon
de faire reculer les extrêmes c'est non
pas d'être envoyé dans un affrontement
de caniveau mais de proposer des
solutions
je vois bien que les attaques
personnelles
il disait il n'est rien et c est tout ça
n'est pas au niveau du débat est la
seule question à se poser c'est est-ce
que cette campagne électorale elle
satisfait les français aujourd'hui je
pense que pour l'instant la réponse
était non pourquoi parce qu'on n'est pas
en train de parler des vrais sujets pour
le pays on est en train de vivre une
révolution qui est au moins équivalente
à la révolution industrielle qu'elle a
vécu au 19e siècle car battu toutes les
cartes entre les états entre les
entreprises entre les différents corps
constitués dans la société française qui
remet en cause la démocratie et bien
c'est à ça qu'on doit apporter des
réponses pas à perdre du temps à parler
à des uns et les autres qui sont plus
outrancier les uns que les autres et
qu'ils se soient absolument perdu
notamment dans le positionnement face à
vladimir poutine pour parler de choses
sérieuses une dernière question sur une
actualité c'est la corse ya eu des
manifestations
hier des milliers de personnes qui ont
défilé dans les rues en soutien à yvan
colonna qui a été agressée en prison son
agresseur présumé a été mis en examen
pour tentative d'assassinât en relation
avec une entreprise terroriste gilles
simeoni président du conseil exécutif
pointe la responsabilité de l'état est
ce qu emmanuel macron et jean castex
peuvent continuer à rester silencieux
sur ce sujet sont peine de voir monter
les tensions dans le monde mais je crois
que ce qui est important c'est qu'on
puisse aller au bout des enquêtes qui
ont été des jantes et évidemment qu'il
faut faire l'entière vérité sur cette
affaire et s'il ya eu des
dysfonctionnements évidemment les dires
les pointer du doigt et les régler il
était pendu vie minutes sur les prendre
c'est pareil sinon colonna a été
condamné et mérite de évidemment
d'effectuer sa peine mais personne ne
mérite d'être assassinée en prison c'est
terrible bien sûr il faut le dire
je pense que c'est une bonne chose que
l'inspection générale de la justice
puisse mener cette enquête interne c'est
une bonne chose que le parquet national
anti terroriste puisse s'emparer du
dossier l'a pu s'exprimer dès hier il
faut que ces enquêtes là puisse se
poursuivre pour faire toute la lumière
j'ai entendu que le président de
l'assemblée s'est prononcée
favorablement à cette idée là moi elle
me choque pas non plus parce qu'il
faudrait pas donner l'impression en tout
cas de regarder ailleurs c'est une
affaire sérieuse elle doit être traitée
comme telle évidemment merci
[Musique]